we've already reached September which
means the kids are back in school in
many parts of the world
it also means another round of free
games for PlayStation Plus subscribers
let's take a look at what this month has
to offer first up on ps4 is destiny -
and it's available right now Bungie
shared world shooter is gearing up for
its next expansion Forsaken very soon
which means it's the perfect time to
dive into the base game even better
it'll include a 24 hour trial of force
Akins new gambit multiplayer mode on
September 1st if you're back on the God
of War train you're in luck as ps4 is
also getting God of War 3 remastered
chronologically this is the last
adventure before this year's Norse based
game in which Kratos climbs out of Hades
all the way up Mount Olympus to get his
revenge on Zeus but wait there's more
sony is still offering those extra
freebies from last month the first is
here they lie a psvr horror games set in
a world full of creepy monsters that'll
be free for PS Plus subscribers until
October 2nd the other game knowledge is
power uses Sony's Play link app letting
everyone participate with just their
smartphones this tactical trivia game
will be available until November 6
moving to ps3 platforming fans can check
out another world 20th anniversary
edition this remaster of the cult
classic includes HD visuals the ability
to switch between the old and new looks
and cross saves that's pretty handy
since it also includes cross-buy with
ps4 and Vita also on ps3 is Cube
director's cut a game in which you
manipulate cubes to solve puzzles this
version includes more Story content and
a new Time Trial mode and you can play
it all on ps4 as well thanks to cross by
Vita fans can get their hands on sparkle
to a puzzle game that's easy to pick up
and hard to master as you match up balls
of the same color
beyond the puzzles it's a story about
escaping from a cursed land and you can
escape it on ps3 and ps4 as well via
cross by finally the Vita is also
getting foul play a beat'em upset on an
ever-changing theater stage the more
performative you are and
combat the more the audience will like
you you can also throw down on ps4 with
cross-buy and those are your free PS
Plus games for September they'll be
available from Tuesday September 4th
until October 1st
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot and be sure to stick
with us as we report on the new PS Plus
games every month
you